a Porsche 718 RS with their throaty roar
and unique mechanics Porter's have
always occupied a special place in arts
of sports car fans portions KU Nirvana
says it's a very pure istic the
technology is rather simple and it's
combined with a race car engine but it's
still reasonably easy to drive and now
another treat is in store for fans of
the brand a new portrush oh the special
future of performance exhibit is on at
berlin's volkswagen group forum until
june
the tiddle future of performance washes
are pinched a scale says the future of
performance epitomizes the brand the
first piece is the 550 spider which set
the DNA also models launched in the
early 1950s the Porsche 550 was a
mainstay on racetracks the world over
winning many a title with 1.5 litres
capacity the four-cylinder boxer engine
achieved about 80 kilowatts and a top
speed of 220 kph in 1954 Porsche made
the cart street-legal just over 100 was
sold 550 soon became an icon in the
Porsche pantheon
the 918 spyder is today's icon a plug-in
hybrid with two electric motors in a v8
engine that delivers 447 kilowatts it
breaks the 7-minute barrier on the
Nurburgring tracks famous north loop
then there's the new 718 Boxster in its
first appearance in Germany like its
namesake the legendary 1950 07 18 the
new model is powered by a four-cylinder
boxer engine
the last time it was used was in the
1970s 09 14 both the celebrated original
and today's version are mid engines
pinterest elf alchemist a scale says the
show closes with the 919 hybrid which
dominated the 2015 racing season so the
berlin exhibition encompasses the
totality of the future sports car
concept alongside the cars on display
the berlin show also offers a peek under
the hood this is currently Porsches most
powerful boxer engine a 580 horsepower
turbocharged s which also powers the new
911
another highlight is an interactive
terminal where visitors can find
additional information and in some of
the models the public is even allowed to
sit in the cockpit the future of
performance show runs until June and
offers a broad overview of the Porsche
mystique but for a more detailed look
you'll want to head for the quarter
Museum in Stuttgart